le voici donc cet album qui a occupé les
jours et les nuits de laurent astier
depuis une bonne année
le temps pour ce perfectionniste de
mener à bien un projet qui lui tenait à
coeur depuis longtemps
j'entame en fait un nouveau genre parce
que moi j'ai fait du polar pendant un
peu plus de 15 ans et j'avais un peu
envie de changer donc du coup j'ai
attaqué un nouveau genre qui est le
western qui est un peu le genre
de jeu révère enfants en fait c'est les
premières bandes dessinées en tout cas
les premières bandes que j'ai que j'ai
dessiné quand j'étais petit c'était du
western dont je reviens un peu un amour
d'enfance le dessinateur que nous avions
rencontrée en plein travail il ya
quelques mois a choisi de faire d'une
femme
l'héroïne de cet album premier d'une
série de cinq ou la violence et c'est
surtout emilie en fait c'est une héroïne
ce qui est assez rare en fait en western
en général c'est un monde qui est assez
masculin est justement moi je voulais
vraiment utiliser ce un personnage
féminin pour pour avoir une autre vision
en fait de cette période de cet
univers-là chez art canix la librairie
du centre ville spécialisé dans la bd la
venin fait son apparition en vitrine et
dans les rayons c'est ici que laurent
astier dédicacera son album vendredi à
un moment stratégique
on sort en fait d'un mois de décembre
qui a été qu'ils étaient bons et riche
en sorties puisque souvent pour la fin
d'année en fait tous les éditeurs
sortent la grosse cavalerie donc là en
fait on reprend tout doucement la le
rythme de croisière avec des sorties qui
vont arriver et en fait nos lecteurs
sont impatientes de les avoir
le 24 janvier prochain s'ouvrira
jusqu'au 27 la 46e édition du festival
d'angoulême où le dessinateur
castelroussins ne passera certainement
pas inaperçu